[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce numéro spécial du sky
échos sur tv 78 nous sommes à plaisir et
plus précisément dans la zone
d'activités sainte apolline pour un
magazine entièrement consacré au leader
mondial de la communication extérieure
le groupe jc decaux
[Musique]
enfin
ok
le monde
bon
créé en
1964 par jean claude decaux cette
société est présente dans plus de 80
pays
abribus affiches grand format ou encore
infrastructures de publicité installés
dans les aéroports les gares et les
métros le site historique de cette
société est ici à plaisir 800
collaborateurs travaillent ici de la
préparation des affiches à la recherche
en développement en passant par le parc
expo que vous voyez derrière moi qui
expose les différents mobiliers urbains
mais avant cela
regardez ce décryptage pour connaître un
peu plus le groupe jc decaux
[Musique]
on est ici sur notre site de plaisir
sainte apolline notre siège historique
monsieur decaux avait l'habitude
d'afficher le long des axes routiers à
l'époque et notamment de la nationale
qui passe à quelques mètres de notre
site et il y avait ce bâtiment
historique qui est le premier bâtiment
de l'entreprise qui est un ancien relais
de la poste et monsieur decaux voilà
c'était dit que son activité ne prenez
pas eh ben il y avait des terres et il
aimait c'est airlie qui pourrait tout
simplement exploiter ces terres
agricoles
[Musique]
nous sommes avec guillaume cayol dans
les coulisses du groupe jc decaux
l'atelier de préparation des affiches
bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire combien
de personnes travaillent ici dans cet
atelier cet atelier à 135 personnes qui
travaillent et au global sur l'a330
préparation qui en france 1 2 dans les
yvelines et en rhône alpes on a au
global de 115 personnes etc alors
quelles sont les différentes étapes de
préparation des affiches la première
étape et la réception de dijon reçoit
des affiches imprimées sur du papier fsc
j'y suis de forêts gérées durablement
ensuite on va la première étape ça va
être la réception des photos qui va être
ensuite complètement
informatisé rentrer dans son système et
ensuite on va préparer l'ensemble des
affiches vous voyez ici comme ça on va
si on va d colisée sa deuxième étape on
va faire du colisage on va dérouler pour
ensuite comme vous allez le voir sur les
images et derrière des colis pour chaque
région chaque affichage va recevoir ces
affiches identifiés pour lui-même donc
là c'est des affiches de quoi en fait
c'est pas forcément la publicité vous
m'avez dire tiens aujourd'hui on nous
prépare un cent mille affiches par
semaine ses doutes ses locaux pendant à
la fois des campagnes pour des
annonceurs nationaux des annonceurs
locaux pour typiquement des commerces de
proximité de la ville de plaisir mais
aussi pour la coller les collectivités
qui nous mine qui pour les gamins ils
peuvent communiquer sur nos dispositifs
sert présent quasiment 20% de notre
préparation donc finalement fait c'est
rouler les affiches pour qu'elle soit le
plus propre possible à l'affichage on va
dérouler en fonction des formats on va
aller rouler on pourrait le demeurer on
le roule le 8 mètres carrés que vous
allez on va avoir maintenant on va les
assemblées en assemblée affiches on va
des scotch ale conditionné on va
déconditionner pour que le travail sur
le terrain soient le plus simple et plus
facile possible pour l'affichage allons
vous justement vous parlez des affiches
de 8 mètres carrés justement vous avez
des nouvelles machines des systèmes
automatiques on va tout de suite aller
découvrir
et nous sommes toujours avec guillaume
carriole pour parler de ce système
automatique qui assemble des affiches de
8 mètres carrés cette fois ci c'est déjà
nicolas dans cette machine est
complètement automatique on a des
machines semi automatique mais cela est
complètement automatique eh bien
m nous comme vous pouvez le voir à
l'écran des avis en charge des affiches
débat d'afficher des olympiques est
automatiquement la machine grâce à des
caméras qui sont positionnées dans la
machine bien repérer des croix
d'assemblage et bien positionner
parfaitement la plus pour avoir un
assemblage parfait sur cette partie là
donc ça c'est un système automatique
mais il ya aussi des collaborateurs qui
font cette activité-là cette activité là
elle est principalement réalisé par nos
collaborateurs puisque plus de la moitié
font dix pour cent des appuis sont
produits par nos collaborateurs chez des
machines semi-automatique la force de jc
decaux c'est d'avoir à la fois des
machines manuel semi automatique est
automatique pour pouvoir adapter notre
outil de production à l'eau type de
campagne que l'on réalise en ou sur la
dernière étape c'est la partie
préparation rangement et ensuite
livraison on a fait le choix c'est ici
d'auto d'internaliser complètement notre
nos livraisons on a treize navette qui
vont parcourir qui partent le lundi
matin le livret l'ensemble de nos sites
en france no 86 et juste avant on a le
rangement de toute la production qui est
systématiquement contre les scanner pour
être sûr d'avoir le jour j à l'heure h
l'ensemble des affiches retraite après
tout en france eh bien merci guillaume
gayole merci des colas directeur des
opérations d'affichage et événementiel
chez jc decaux et le sky echos' poursuit
direction le parc expo pour découvrir
les différents mobiliers urbains
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint isabelle marie
directrice des projets stratégiques chez
jc decaux bonjour bonjour
alors avec vous on va parcourir
l'histoire du groupe à travers ces
mobiliers urbains alors déjà comment ont
évolué et mobilier urbain jc decaux
alors ils vont évidemment évolué même si
et vous envoyer plein d'exemples ici
autour de vous sur ce parc expo du
campus de de plaisir
l'abribus c'est vraiment un des services
les plus développés en france et dans le
monde par jc decaux et c'est avant tout
un service donc un service qui a
profondément changé depuis 1964 la
mobilité dans les villes donc
aujourd'hui par exemple en france on a
plus 3000 collectivités locales parmi
nos partenaires et ce mobilier bien sûr
il sert à attendre le bus
confortablement
il a un design qui est spécifique et
très particulier et c'est une des
valeurs cardinales chez jc decaux que de
travailler ce design et il accueille des
fonctions alors au fil du temps il a
accueilli des fonctions par exemple
d'information voyageurs très important
aux mobilités et petit à petit en fait
il s'est enrichi d'autres services je
vous donne un exemple des prises usb
quand on est à court de batterie on peut
se brancher sous un abribus et passer
son passé son coup de fil ces mobiliers
urbains qui ont toujours leur fonction
première qui ont toujours ce design qui
a aussi son importance a évolué pour
intégrer de nouvelles fonctions
concernant les autres mobiliers urbains
parce que jc decaux ce ne sont pas
uniquement les abribus quels sont les
autres types de mobilier urbain qu'on
retrouve alors il y à des services comme
par exemple les sanitaires entretien
automatique dont nous fêtons d'ailleurs
ces jours derniers les 40 ans de
développement chez jc decaux c'est un
sujet très important le lit viennent sur
l'espace public
donc ça c'est une typologie de service
on a par exemple
aussi on est passé devant elle les
colonnes morris en tout cas les colonnes
d'affichage culturel
donc elle incarne la politique
culturelle des villes elles sont plus en
gestes design qui est souvent
magnifiques donc c'est aussi ça fait
aussi partie des des services aux
collectivités locales et aux citoyens
que nous avons développée est alors au
delà du mobilier urbain jc decaux vous
êtes aussi présent dans les usages en
termes de mobilité douce un oui tout à
fait et sur les mobilités douces et en
particulier le vélo en libre service
c'est une activité que nous avons
développée dès 2003 à vienne puis étendu
en france donc aujourd'hui par exemple
en france on opère dans 43 collectivités
locales et le taux de satisfaction
global de nos systèmes qui est vraiment
plébiscité par les utilisateurs et de
92% donc ça répond à une attente très
forte dans les centres urbains ont une
attente des collectivités locales comme
des citoyens pour une mobilité plus
partagés plus douce à merci isabelle
marie je vous en prie directrice des
projets stratégiques chez jc decaux et
maintenant qu'on va aborder avec vous la
question des usages innovants et bien
allons rejoindre tout de suite qu'en
dise marion pour parler de l'innovation
technologique chez jc decaux
[Musique]
ils sont près de 150 ingénieurs à
travailler au quotidien sur les
innovations au sein du groupe jc decaux
pour en parler nous sommes avec candice
marion bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
non
alors dans un premier temps dit nous
c'est les produits de demain sa seconde
derrière nous alors exactement ce sont
les produits de demain alors déjà
l'innovation elle irrigue le groupe tous
les métiers et tous les collaborateurs
sont inspirés elle vient du modèle aussi
innovant le business model de jc decaux
quête pour lire des mobiliers et des
services et toutes les fonctionnalités
qu'ils soient entretenus gratuitement
pour les collectivités est financé par
la publicité et ce business model bien
ils nous inspirent ils inspirent les
collaborateurs mais il inspire aussi les
partenaires avec lesquels on travaille
on a des start up des petites des
grandes entreprises qui viennent le voir
et qu'ils veulent brainstorm est avec
nous sur ces nouveaux usages des
services aux collectivités ou notamment
des digitales pour la communication
extérieure et ensuite on va développer
très rapidement des preuves de concept
des proof of concept en deux trois mois
en terme de faisabilité technique
concerné la solution on s'inspire de
nouveaux usages on travaille avec nos
directions marketing de direction design
nos partenaires qui nous complète
l'expertisé et on va proposer un concept
on pourra ensuite expérimenté avec les
collectivités alors on a un exemple
parce que là on en a beaucoup derrière
nous alors j'ai besoin d'amener quelques
exemples sur la partie digital et
services pour les pour les collectivités
par exemple alors le fil très haut c'est
à l'abri innovant qui va améliorer la
qualité de l'air pour les usagers qui
attendent sous l'abri quand on a imaginé
ce concept on a scruté déjà toutes les
solutions technologiques on pouvait
avoir on est allé rencontrer des
partenaires des laboratoires de
recherche on s'est fait accompagner par
exemple par l'inra qui nous a convaincus
sur le fait que la végétalisation
permettait d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air alors quand on a quelque part qu
en ville ça améliore de quelques pour
cent mais lorsqu'on a une barrière
végétale ça peut améliorer jusqu'à 30%
et donc on a imaginé mettre sur les
toits cette solution de filtration on a
imaginé également sur une mousse parce
qu elle est légère et les vivas facile à
entretenir elle est donc très durable et
qui va faire une barrière
végétal aux polluants et permettent par
un système piloté de ventilation
d'améliorer l'usagé pour
les personnes qui attendent sous les
abris et aujourd'hui on est en train de
l'expérimenter avec des jeans on a
installé dans deux villes en france et
on complète cette expérimentation avec
des premières analyses qui sont
réconfortantes sur le sujet dans quelle
ville alors on l'installé sur lille et
strasbourg et les premiers résultats là
qu'on commence à à dépouiller son sursis
sur lui on a repéré deux tendances 1
pendant la crise sanitaire une
transformation digitale et la transition
environnementale là vous venez de donner
l'exemple que la transition
environnementale vous la prenez déjà en
compte chez jc decaux qu'en est il de la
transformation digitale alors la
transformation digitale également elle
est très présente vous voyez tous les
écrans qui nous entourent aujourd'hui on
a toutes les solutions de diffusion
digitale qu'on propose en communication
extérieure et qui complète complètement
les canal de communication à plus
classiques on sur lesquels on assure
déjà du temps réel de la
contextualisations un message au bon
moment au bon endroit et des biens sur
toute la qualité de diffusion et puis la
sécurité des diffusions et à côté de ça
on va proposer également des mobiliers
plus innovants vous voyez qui sur la
droite avec des solutions de micro led
qui sont intégrés qui améliore le
contraste des solutions d'écrans
transparents de l'interactivité avec les
usagers et on propose là dessus des
solutions interactives c'est à dire que
la personne à l'usager va se retrouver
devant une offre de service gigantesque
avec il va pouvoir en fait manipuler et
interagir et qui va lui permettre
d'aller sur sur des services merci
candice marion je vous en prie mais
rappelle que vous êtes directrice
adjointe 1ère et des nouveaux concepts
et produits innovants chez jc decaux et
c est ainsi que se conclut ce sky échos
merci de l'avoir suivi vous pourrez
revoir cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
m